the sudden rapid upswing in coronavirus
cases has brought the most stringent
restrictions on how we lead our lives
since the war cases are now doubling
every five to six days and London is a
few weeks ahead of the rest of the
population with hospitals seeing a surge
of admissions this is what the
government is are now asking everybody
to do once someone has a dry cough or
fever everybody who lives with them
friends or family should completely
isolate themselves for 14 days everybody
who can should work from home
unnecessary travel should be reduced or
stopped social gatherings big or small
should also be reduced and people should
avoid pubs clubs restaurants and
theatres everyone is being asked to join
what is in effect a social curfew to
slow the viruses spread but three groups
in particular being urged to minimize
social contact those are over 70 younger
adults with underlying health conditions
who would normally qualify for a flu jab
and as a precaution pregnant women the
aim is to reduce cases so the NHS isn't
overwhelmed these new measures have a
big effect this is not a series of small
interventions you would anticipate that
this could have a dramatic effect to
reduce the peak and to reduce death rate
they are not easy but they are important
and they will have the effect if we all
do it this is a matter for us to take
accountability to make sure we help each
other protect ourselves and protect the
NHS these measures shift the
government's strategy from mitigation
towards suppression computer modelling
by Imperial College had suggested that
optimal mitigation policies might reduce
peak healthcare demand by two-thirds and
deaths by half their research also
suggests that attempts to slow the
viruses spread would still result in
critical care capacity being overwhelmed
with surge limits for critical care beds
being exceeded by eight fold 250,000
people would
the stringent social distancing outlined
today should reduce those deaths but
school and university closures may still
be needed
and although the measures might be eased
temporarily if pressure on hospitals
reduced the virus would bounce back and
they may have to last for 18 months
until we had supplies of a vaccine